I'm talking about plastic surgery.
Let's get into it. I want to talk about
it. I want to talk about it.
What the f*** is going on, man?
What the f*** is going on?
Plastic surgery is at an all time high.
I don't even know if you know this, but
back in the day, plastic surgery was a
secret. Like nobody wanted anybody to
know that they were getting work done.
It was all nose jobs and titty jobs,
nose titties, nose titties, nose
titties. That's all it was back in the
day. People got mad at the doctor.
You better not say shit about what
happened here today. Only two people
that we knew that got work done back in
the day was Dolly Parton and Michael
Jackson. That's a fucking fact.
Those are the only two people Mike
showed up with that new nose.
We knew. That's not your nose, Mike.
Something happened. It's not the same
nose. Today is different.
Everybody's getting work done. Men,
women, women have taken it to a new
level, though. The new shit that the
women are doing is The BBL.
The bbl.
What the f***?
Jesus Christ.
These bitches look like ants.
That's right. I said it.
They look like ants.
Somebody got to say it.
Somebody's got to say it.
And if you don't believe me, I challenge
you to go look at a picture of an ant
and tell me I'm f***ing lying.
Big ass head, little neck, hard chest,
skinny waist, fat ass.
You ever see an ant?
Ass? Ants.
Ants got ass. You ever seen an ass?
If I was an insect, I'd f*** an ant.
Swear to God. I'll do it.
Everybody wants change.
Everybody's looking for change.
A friend of mine's got a huge forehead,
right? One of the worst foreheads I've
ever seen in my f***ing life. Huge.
Told me the other day, he said, Kev,
I'm thinking about getting my forehead
reduced. This is what he said to me.
I couldn't believe what the f*** I
heard. I said, What the f*** did you
just say to me? He said, I'm thinking
about getting my forehead reduced.
I already talked to my doctor. He said
he can do it. The average forehead is
four fingers wide.
He said, I've got an 8 to 12 finger
situation going on. Well, he can flip
it down. He said he can flip it down.
Flip it down.
That's not a hat. What are you talking
about?
It's a f***ing forehead, bitch.
What about your brain, you said.
Well, he can push that back.
He can push that back.
Raise my eyes up so I can see better.
I bet you f***ing will!
Everybody wants change.
Lebron James, real good friend of mine,
well, he was he hasn't heard this joke
yet. We'll see what happens.
We'll see what happens. I remember in
the beginning of LeBron's career, he
was going bald. His hair was real thin
up top. You could count the hairs on
top of his f***ing head.
You know how I know that? Because I was
the one counting the hairs on top of
his f***ing head.
One.
Two ish.
Ish.
I didn't see Brian for like three weeks.
I didn't see him and I didn't talk to
him. Brian showed up at a wedding I was
at. He had a head full of hair, walked
in that bitch with all his confidence.
Like, I didn't see him three weeks ago
with the f***ing truth on his goddamn
head. He walked in.
He was like, what up? What up. What up.
What up. What up. What up. What up.
What up. What's going on?
I said, what the f*** is going on with
you? The f*** is out of your goddamn
head. People start kicking me.
Chill, calm, chill. I said get your
f***ing feet off of me. Ain't no chill.
I want to know what the f*** that is on
Brian Head. I'll tell you what it's
not. I knew what it wasn't.
I knew it wasn't a goddamn toupee.
I knew that much.
You know how I knew it wasn't a toupee?
Because they don't make toupees.
They never have. They never have.
The f*** is that on your head, LeBron?
Is it alive?
Snatch it off right now.
I wanted to. He's tall.
I can't-- get no way. I'm getting that.
But you get what I'm saying.